we're blessed to both you out of here
but from that one you work for me
advantage me that laugh could only
belong to one person Kevin Hart he plays
a buddy who come to the rescue of louis
c.k in the secret life of pets but you
know Kevin's the one actually looking
for help in real life because his home
was broken into two weeks ago and the
suspects are still at large but leave it
to Kevin to turn it into something fun
oh it's over for you
it's over for you you hear me that's
Kevin's threat to the crooks who broke
in as a joke he even posted a fake
picture asking his 37 million followers
to help catch the guy so you share all
your [ __ ] my house has been robbed three
times if I don't tell people if I said
yeah house rock through house
somebody somebody comes to my house
sometimes to take some stuff that's
between me and him I'm not gonna tell
the police world has to know the Kevin
Hart's mansion got robbed now we're out
for revenge Kevin is just as crazy in
their new movie together
The Secret Life of pets Kevin's the
rabbit Lois the lonely pooch together
they cheer up New York City
who you have a dog I do have a dog yes
three she's it's my third dog yeah
that's like ex-wives you know like I got
lunch ex-wives I'm on my third dog
workout we're still trying to figure it
out before got two kids with my second
dog I've got three puppies with my first
and third dog I feel like if she's
younger and we're trying to work it out